Joshua I understand the act of killing
is now banned in Indonesia is that
correct no it'sit's not bad actually we
knew that if we release the film in
cinemas we would have right after we
made it we would have to submit it to
the censors in Indonesia and we knew
then that it was likely to be banned
particularly before there was any
support for the film in Indonesia
Indonesia still does bad films and in
particular they banned films dealing
with human rights violations and we knew
and so and we knew that if the films
banned then it becomes illegal to screen
it at all and that would be an excuse if
you like for the paramilitary group or
or the army to physically attack
screenings with impunity so to avoid
that situation so that the film could
come out in Indonesia all last autumn we
held screenings at the National Human
Rights Commission in Jakarta for indeed
Indonesia's leading news publishers news
editors news producers Indonesia's
leading filmmakers historians writers
educators some human rights advocates
survivors groups all of them really
loved the film and perhaps the most
extraordinary thing happened with the
news producers and news news publishers
if you're the editor of Indonesia's
largest news magazine for example you're
part of the establishment and you're
late you're in your late middle age and
you see in the act of killing men who
are perpetrators were the founding
fathers of this regime and you see them
at the end of the film totally destroyed
by what they've done either broken as in
the case of Anwar or in the case of Adi
the other death squad member in the film
totally Hollow empty shells and you're
faced with a pretty stark choice do you
want to grow old like them as
perpetrators or do you want to take a
stance and news outlet after news outlet
decided they would break in reaction to
the film break their official silence on
the killing
break their decades-long silence on the
killings Indonesia's largest News
magazine produced a special double
edition of the magazine in which they
felt they should marshal fresh evidence
their own evidence to show that the act
of killing is a repeatable experiment it
documents something systemic
to the society they sent journalists all
over the country dozens of journalists
like 40 to see if they could find
killers elsewhere who would talk like
Anwar to their horror but not to their
astonishment they found that everywhere
they said journalists they were men like
Anwar who would boast and they collected
two in two weeks hundreds of pages of
boasting they edited it down to 75 pages
they produced another 25 pages about the
movie and came out with a double edition
of their magazine on the first of
October last year about the film the
other news outlets followed suit and
Indonesia for the first time has really
started talking about what happened in
65 the film has come to Indonesia
exactly like the child in the Emperor's
New Clothes pointing at the king saying
the king is naked everybody had been
afraid to say it now it's been said so
openly by the perpetrators themselves
that people everyone else can start
talking about it without fear
so everyone who saw the film last autumn
we said look go back to your communities
show the film if it's by invitation we
probably don't have to show the film to
the censors they did so on the 10th of
December last year international human
rights day there were 50 screenings in
30 cities ranging in size from 30 people
as the smallest the smallest about 600
700 people with the largest that's grown
ever since on the 1st of April we passed
500 screenings in 95 cities and every
week there's more than the previous week
so the film is really fundamentally
opening this space where Indonesians can
both talk about what happened and
address the nature of the impunity and
the fear and the corruption and the
gangsterism that has been built on the
celebration of atrocity as something
heroic
you